Tina is in New York hi Tina welcome to
the Dave Ramsey show how can John
Delaney and I help you yeah what's up
all right so just to let you know I'm a
huge fan of yours I listen to you were
almost every day and we went through
your program almost 15 years ago and
successfully you know went through the
whole program completed it sometimes the
word Dave is still a bad name in my
fortune imagine so I have four children
ranging from the ages of 20 to 24 I had
a set of twins in there so don't get
nervous we were lucky enough because of
going through this program to be able to
get our kids through college debt-free
and buy them all their first used car in
cash Wow my oldest daughter is 24 just
graduated college this year and just got
a job as a nurse you know making $75,000
right and she refused to live at home
after she graduated so I kind of talked
her into buying a house instead of
throwing money away at rent she had
enough money in her savings for a down
payment you know in an emergency fund
but I told her she had to pay that money
back within the next one or two years so
but now she's been talking about getting
you know about getting a new car or
getting another car and financing it and
also wants to get a credit card because
now she can afford it and when I try to
talk to her to get her you know to
understand you know she gets combative
with me and says that you know I'm not
financially supporting her anymore
and she's not living at home so I can't
control her anymore and that she's an
adult and she has to learn by her own
mistake you know what you know what you
know what the problem is she's right
that's good say you should take my seat
here you're better at this enough oh
it's so frustrating I think the hardest
part Tina I think the hardest parenting
you ever do is with grown children
because stupid is not illegal with her
together I think you've had too many
yeah you've had them and here's the deal
you've lived it you've set the example
she's gonna get maxed out she's gonna
fall down and she's gonna remember
Mama's right and then she's good I
there's that great go in that hole
there's not a let there is right there's
that old quote that old uh that old
quote by Mark Twain it was man when I
was 14 my my dad was the dumbest guy I
ever met and I was stunned when I turned
21 at how much he had learned in seven
years like the my parents man when I was
just graduated college my mom and dad
had so much to learn and the older I get
they are so wise and so loving and so
remarkable so she'll come back she'll
come back but just hitting her over a
stick is gonna drive her drive her
further away you you what you're doing
is not working right so this was my
daughter here's what I would do yeah I
would have to let her go because she's
24 and stupids not illegal now what I
have learned with grown kids because
they work here and I'm also their boss
in some cases so I
but even then I treat them like I do
another team member and that is I give
them the dignity of being an adult not a
child and you're still treating her with
your mom voice kiddo she ain't gonna
hear your mom voice anymore she just put
you on notice no more mom voice and so
what you're gonna have to use is your
friend voice have you got some friends
that are that have kids about the same
age oh yeah okay if one of those kids
was misbehaving you would use a
different language and a different tone
to convince and persuade them than
you've been using with your daughter
wouldn't you wouldn't you yeah no no no
she's not doing she's not doing drugs
she's getting a credit card there's a
difference okay I agree she's being
stupid and really disrespectful because
she grew up in a financial peace
household I get that it's offensive
it's worrisome it's all those things but
no I I you know the only shot you have
at persuading a grown child is the
persuasion tone of a friend not the
mother octave when I drop into my dad
octave and they hear me being daddy
they're tapes from their childhoods
start playing in their head and then
instantaneously something switches in
their head and the shields go up and
they go wait just a dadgum minute I'm an
adult you don't get to treat me that way
anymore and that's exactly what she's
saying and and I've seen people do it
and my friends circle because we're
about the same age Tina and we've got
these grown kids issues and you know I
they don't even treat their own kids the
way I think they should well in in Tina
you mentioned something that that I just
want to speak to this is your oldest
daughter she's graduated college she's
now a nurse that means she can stick
needles in people and help people heal
so people up and all the stuff you're
gonna have to exhale and let her grow up
and I know that as having number one
here that's hard she didn't want to move
back in with you would have been so good
to get all your chickens back in the
nest incoming she's a grownup chicken
she got a fly and she goes she's gonna
fall down she's gonna get chased by
Cody's and whatever she's gonna be all
right because he raised her right and
you raised her with values and you
raised her to be connected and to love
you but you got to let her go the
horrible thing is you raised them up to
be successful adults and then dead Gump
they don't do it without you I want them
to raise them up to leave and then they
do my promise is I'm gonna hug my
daughter Josephine for you extra tonight
just for you that's my that's my promise
yeah and that's what you need to just
say honey I love you
and even when you're stupid I still
that's all you can do yeah thanks for
the call there's a really good call it's
very important it really is I mean you
get the call all the time these people
that are you know how do I get my friend
to not leash the car how do I get my
daughter tonight how do I get my mom and
dad to save money they're in their 50s
and they misbehave their whole lives and
they're gonna retire broke and I'm gonna
have to feed them later you don't know
we you can't you can control your locus
of control your action it's not your
control the only thing you can control
is you mm-hmm and god it's so
frustrating to watch people you love
bring harm to themselves because of
their stupidity it's very frustrating
just letting them know I'll be here when
you get back